nucléaire éolien solaire quel mix
énergétique en france dans 30 ans dans
quelle proportion les énergies
renouvelables doivent-elles être
développées peut-on se passer du
nucléaire en 2050 on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le compte et dégradent rt
france le débat est ouvert avec notre
face à face tout de suite
et avec nous pour en parler yves
contassot membre d'europe écologie les
verts c'est que valérie de bord
porte-parole de xavier bertrand bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
ils font des sauts avant d'entrer dans
le vif du débat sur cette question du
nucléaire déjà ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec yannick jadot qui dit que ce
rapport de la rte et est biaisé en
faveur de l'exécutif
écoutez on peut faire trois remarques
sur le rapport de rte d'abord il y avait
trois hypothèses de départ possibles qui
était celle de m
hypothèse avec de la sobriété c'est à
dire que mon supprimait tout le gâchis
est sûre consommations inutiles une
hypothèse haute et une très haute
rte a choisi l'hypothèse haute elle n'a
pas choisi la sobriété deuxième élément
nous re calcul et ses coûts
rte n'applique absolument pas toutes les
données qui sont celles de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie pas des
gauchistes pas des écologistes est
manifestement effect a surestimé dans
son rapport tout l'écho des
renouvelables est sous-estimé tous les
coupes du nucléaire et enfin dernier
élément
comme d'ailleurs le gouvernement r tu
envisages la relance du nucléaire sur
des technologies qui aujourd'hui
n'existe pas
ils'agit de le pr2 deuxième génération
ou des mrc totti
acteur ni l'une ni l'autre de cette
technologie n'est au point aujourd'hui
et dans le meilleur des cas on nous dit
qu'elle arriverait peut-être
être ensemble 2040 donc on voit qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans la trajectoire
qui est celle de l'accord de paris de la
baisse des émissions et d'autre part
simplement de la baisse du prix de
l'énergie
valérie de bord donc pour revenir voilà
à cette question que je posais à
l'instant à yves contassot un rapport
biaisé justement en faveur de de la
politique que soit adopté le l'exécutif
et je penserai parce qu'un rapport on
n'a pas le conflit jeunes qu'on ne fait
pas forcément dire qu'ils les bleesés
parce qu'on est un peu facile après je
considère qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
important pour les français c'est la
sûreté la qualité et le coût de
l'énergie
bonjour particulièrement en ces temps
difficiles où l'augmentation notamment
ray du gaz les coûts liés au futur
extrêmement important le comité devait
effectivement garantir aux français une
énergie accessible à un tarif qui ne
soit pas trop important et nous qu'est
ce que nous voulons c'est que à chaque
fois qu'on essaie de reculer sur les mix
énergétique qui doit-être nous
considérons avant tout composée de mmes
est clair et bien nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation complexe je vais pas
revenir ici sur la fermeture de
fessenheim mais néanmoins on à fermer
fessenheim que s'est il passé c'est chez
moi les allemands ont ouvert des
centrales à charbon et aujourd'hui des
difficultés d'alimentation à cause de
cela six coups de la tête et que se
trouve que ce n'est pas nous qui le
disons c'est vos propres amis qui se
tiendra donc on voit très bien
aujourd'hui que les décisions qui ont
été prises par ce gouvernement
parfaitement idéologique on trouve leurs
finalités et ne peuvent plus perdurer il
est absolument nécessaire de façon
pragmatique et absolument secure est
bien d'avancer sur cette logique plus la
logique est temps d'avoir une énergie
décarbonée je rappelle je vais vous la
réalité et ainsi le nucléaire et des
questions qu'on ne se retrouve jamais
avec une galère une énergie qu'on peut
produire avec également des moyens de
production que nous pouvons avoir on
parle de 2050 donc il ya moyen pour sa
recherche des crevasses et là dessus
et je trouverais assez étrange de me
parler sur ses énergiques l'éolien
aujourd'hui est extrêmement décriait à
une qualité de roulement qui est
extrêmement décrié un niveau production
également très décriée et puis il ya
d'autres
modélisation des canifs aussi on va
poursuivre évidemment ce débat qui est
déjà bien lancée on va regarder une
première réaction celle de de pascal qui
nous écrit donc sur le compte et les
gradins d'ayrté france objectivement si
on tente de s'en passer du nucléaire
donc non seulement on le paiera très
cher financièrement mais aussi
climatiquement réaction pragmatique yves
contassot de pascal qui voient les prix
d'énergie grimpé à une vitesse folle
comme tous les français
clairement on ne peut pas s'en passer on
n'a pas plutôt les moyens de s'en passer
d'ailleurs barbara pompili la nuit elle
aussi difficile de s'en passer pour un
tas de raisons et la première économie
il contassot
là c'est tout l'art est regardé le prix
du kilowattheure nucléaire
alors qu'au delà du fait qu'on n'arrive
même pas à le produire pour l'instant
avec les verts qu'il s'agisse de la
france de la finlande de de l'angleterre
même de la chine qui est obligé de
l'arrêter de personne n'arrive à
produire un kilowattheure sérieusement
d'une part en sécurité et l'autre par le
prix avancé est d'à peu près cinq fois à
six fois celui produit par les énergies
renouvelables donc autrement dit le
nucléaire coûte de plus en plus cher sur
le nucléaire français il ya un mensonge
gigantesque c'est qu'on a on incorpore
pas dans le prix du nucléaire le prix le
traitement des déchets d'une part le
prix de démantèlement des centrales
d'autre part je veux juste prendre un
exemple brennilis
fermé en 1985
aujourd'hui on est à 40 fois le prix
estimé
en 85 pour son démantèlement qui n'a
toujours pas commencé car on ne sait pas
le faire et donc on nous dit en 2040
vont élire en 2040 peut-être qu'on aura
fait le démantèlement de brennilis et
les déchets
je rappelle quand même que pour certains
déchets la durée de vie approche les
trois cent mille ans autrement dit vous
imaginez le nombre de générations
derrière nous qui aurons à gérer ses
déchets évidemment tout ça on dit on le
prend pas en compte financièrement sinon
le nucléaire ne serait pas du tout
rentable et donc la bonne solution c'est
évidemment l'énergie la moins chère
possible c'est-à-dire d'abord la
sobriété elle pour éviter le gâchis est
ensuite les énergies renouvelables qui m
une fois l'installation mise en place
coûte quasiment rien alors vous allez
devoir vous soutenez xavier bertrand
pour qui clairement le nucléaire il a
dit et on a une énergie d'avenir donc
c'est dire que vous n'êtes pas du tout
sur la même ligne que notre ami yves
contassot ce soit
alors je crois que c'est un euphémisme
parce que si je suis la même logique que
la sienne et bien accord pour vous dans
le prix léolia le coût patrimonial de
nos paysages détruit par l'éolien encore
pour moi également le coût la
destruction de ces pics et dans leurs
lourds en béton qui sont aujourd'hui
dans l'état
faisons exactement la même chose ensuite
il faut être je pense extrêmement
cohérent et pragmatiques comme vous
l'avez dit ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir aussi la sécurité de
l'alimentation
on voit très bien que le gars à ce n'est
pas ces kurdes en ce moment mouvant et
complexe
aujourd'hui je constellation pourra
certainement être d'accord avec monsieur
content à 100 mais nucléaire nous
produisons chez nous en france nous
alimentons également de nombreux pays
donc c'est aussi de ce point de vue une
source intéressante de revenus et puis
ça permet d'avoir une sécurité
d'alimentation donc en la matière ne
s'agit pas de dire il faut aucune
énergie renouvelable ça serait
dogmatique et il ne s'agit pas d'aller
là dessus il faut aujourd'hui travailler
sur les énergies du futur on a
d'ailleurs en la matière la chance
d'avoir en france des chercheurs
parfaitement intéressant et qui peuvent
apporter des solutions mais dire
aujourd'hui comme a tenté de le faire ce
gouvernement au début du quinquennat eh
bien nous allons de façon irrémédiable
et nous réfléchi supprimer le nucléaire
arrive à une situation inextricable
comme celle ci où maintenant
effectivement encore une fois par
pragmatisme le gouverement dit on ne
peut pas s'en passer c'est aujourd'hui
ce qui est plus sûr et de moins cher en
alimentation pour les français et donc
on revient là dessus encore une fois on
aurait mieux fait de pas fermer
fessenheim
ils feront face aux élections je vais
vous laisser un répondre mais dans la
lignée de ce que nous dit avait d'abord
il ya ce message dans gêne en force les
gens à acheter des véhicules électriques
alors qu'en forte période et hivernale
en france il ya justement des coupures
de courant ce n'est pas avec des
éoliennes que ça va réellement compenser
nous dit donc angèle
votre réponse justement sur
nucléaire qui est quand même la manière
la plus pérenne d'offrir pas du courant
aujourd'hui en france
écoutez moi je note les contradictions
dans ce café vient de dire gbagbo on
nous dit on à fermer fessenheim on est
obligé de rouvrir les centrales à
charbon en allemagne et deux minutes
après nous dit avec le nucléaire c'est
merveilleux on arrive à alimenter plein
de pays où tout va alors soit on n'a pas
assez de production en france et dans
ces cas là il faut pas nous dire que on
en vend à tout le monde c'est pas très
sérieux en fait on le sait bien on a
aujourd'hui une incapacité de
gouvernement et sa dot pas que de
monsieur macron à avoir une vision un
peu sérieuse des choses qu'on a pris un
retard considérable
je vais vous donner juste à un chiffre
la plupart des centrales nucléaires
arriveront à 59 à la même période bien
avant que les nouvelles centrales
nucléaires envisagées sont en capacité
de fonctionner elles arriveront tout à
l'échéance à peu près en même temps avec
un risque majeur qui est de plusieurs
ordres d'abord un risque que ya des
incidents qu'elles soient plus en état
personne n'est capable aujourd'hui de
dire quelle est la sécurité d'une cuve
qui est le coeur une
du système nucléaire et qu'on ne peut
pas changer
personne n'est capable de dire si ces
cuves peuvent résister plus de 50 ans
l'asn elle même dit je ne veux pas me
prononcer nous n'avons aucun retour
d'expérience donc un risque majeur
deuxième risque c'est un risque
financier s'il faut les refaire c'est
des dizaines de milliards par
enfin pas pour chaque centrale mais au
total on chiffre à environ 150 milliards
le renouvellement totalement illusoire
de penser qu'on peut le financer et donc
il ya un risque aussi c'est qu'on ait
des coupures mais gigantesque
d'électricité et que pour le coup on
n'arrive plus à faire face aux besoins
donc on voit bien que tout ça n'est pas
très sérieux pas très réfléchie et les
meilleurs experts d'ailleurs en
conviennent quelle que soit leur point
de vue sur le nucléaire les disques il
ya un risque qui est majeure je voudrais
vous faire écouter yves contassot pour
vous soutenir dans votre propos adrien
quoi tendance à la france insoumise un
parti de jean luc mélenchon qui va
justement dans votre sens écoutée
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
sans recourir au nucléaire c'est
possible affirmé le contraire n'est pas
sérieux c'est un choix politique étayée
par des experts c'est celui que nous
faisons avec jean luc mélenchon
politique nous dit-on chez mélenchon qui
rajoute comme le disais à l'instant yves
contassot comprend aussi un pari
extrêmement risqué avec le nucléaire
c'est tout simplement dangereux jean luc
mélenchon explique il ya des industries
chimiques qui sont concentrés dans les
mêmes zones que le nucléaire un accident
et c'est fini nous lisent et il à
l'époque qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cette inquiétude qu ont certains
français
jacques ont déjà la première chose c'est
que quand je parlais de la possibilité
de match par cela évidemment de la
technologie de compassion et connaisseur
du sujet pour ne pas l'avoir compris
deuxième élément par rapport à cela vous
savez c'est pas parce qu'on a peur de
quelque chose qui va arriver en 2050
qu'on ne doit pas agir en 2021
aujourd'hui on a tout à fait la
possibilité est bien de mettre en place
des protections de m place des travaux
notamment sur le retraitement des
déchets je vous rappelle que le sujet et
notamment le projet 6 géo qui se trouve
également dans ma région en meuse qui a
pour vocation de travailler sur le
retraitement des déchets avec un
enfouissement qu'on voit que ce
dispositif travail existe depuis 20 ans
on y travaille depuis vingt ans il ya
des tests qui se fait en la matière il
ya des solutions qui commencent à
émerger et ce n'est pas en disant bien
il va se passer quelque chose en 2050 de
vous on devine strictement tout arrêté
que ça va permettre aux français d'avoir
une énergie de meilleure qualité sans
coupure et surtout un tarif raisonnable
c'est exactement l'inversé la peur
n'évite pas le danger et cette façon de
dire ne faisons rien et arrêtons tout
n'est absolument pas sujette à une
alliée et kossou d'avenir donc nous ce
que nous pensons au contraire c'est
qu'avec la qualité de nos scientifiques
avec la qualité notre recherche avec
notre capacité toujours d'avoir une
longueur d'avancé eh bien nous devons
faire confiance nous devons avancer nous
devons continuer effectivement la
recherche extra en la matière les choses
doivent progresser avant d y compris et
bien évidemment sur la sécurité il ne
s'agit pas de se départir de sécurité et
en france je pense que de ce point de
vue que nous avons avec le lançant des
dispositifs suffisamment contrairement à
d'autres pays et l'argent conviens avec
vous monsieur concasseuse n'ait pas le
même système que dans d'autres pays où
je ne tiendrais certainement pas le même
discours mais en tout cas dans notre
grille ce n'est pas la même chose donc
regardons avant tout comme on nous nous
assurons cette alimentation un coût qui
permettra à chaque français d'avoir
aussi des traitements parce que tout le
monde doit pouvoir y accéder encore une
fois on est tous pour le véhicule
électrique c'est un petit peu ce que
disait à la téléspectatrice tout à
l'heure moi la première vous je
l'imaginais il comprit le vélo
électrique mais tout ça il faudra que sa
salive à un moment et avec quoi nous
l'alimenter si nous n'avons pas au moins
cette garantie avec un mix énergétique
un pied concret et réel ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas aujourd'hui les
autres énergies noblat il compte à son
la réponse est le mot de la fin pour
vous la réponse elle est simple d'abord
dans les six scénarios de rte il y en a
un qui est 100% renouvelable l'oublié un
peu ça veut dire que même rte reconnaît
que 100% renouvelable c'est
techniquement faisable et que ça permet
de faire face à la consommation y
compris hôte qu'il retient qui est
pratiquement le double d'une
consommation qui sera basée sur la
sobriété et je vous renvoie d'ailleurs
au scénario mais
je ne peux pas vous laisser mentir je
suis désolé de vous le dire mais
aujourd'hui les l'énergie la moins chère
en terme de l'électricité ce sont les
énergies renouvelables ça n'est pas
discutable vous pourrez prendre tous les
chiffres la cour des comptes
cour des comptes le reconnaît elle parle
d'échec d'échec pour le p r les princes
les suivants sont estimés à 9 sur le
nucléaire
c'est parce que j'ai dit ah bon j'ai dit
le père n'est pas tout le nucléaire vous
pouvez pas dire ça j'ai dit c'est
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui c'est les
six projets que vous et vos amis
mais c'est tous les projets aujourd'hui
repose sur le p r ou des sms qu'ils ne
sont pas plus opérationnel donc
autrement dit vous faites un espèce de
l'a pas
écouté il y en a aucun qui fonctionne
moi c'est ce que je vois et edf 10 10 11
étaient prêts à pour vérifier si un jour
c'est faisable et qu'en tout état cause
ce sera pas avant 2035 2040
mais nous mettons y être arrivé c'est
pas en 2050 qu'on va commencer vous avez
l'air de dire que le dérèglement
climatique maintenant
évaluée
maintenant je note simplement que
l'allemagne à 30000 éoliennes nous en 0
éoliennes offshore 00 nous sommes très
très belle l'allemagne se chauffe au
charme et
vous avez changeriez vous remercie en
tout cas merci à tous
je suis stabilisé
merci
merci également avec des deux bords
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce face à
face ce soir